wie kommt denn dieses jahr hierhin ist
das vielleicht ein ufo parkplatz und hat
das wovor beim start dieses loch
hinterlassen an der küste von
nordengland
dieses loch heißt sauter hohen es
entsteht im jahr 2003 zunächst als
kleines loch wird aber von jahr zu jahr
größer zu bestaunen in mit burn wirklich
von sutherland an der nordöstlichen
englischen küste
beeindruckend dass das loch auch weil
das meerwasser dort nun einen kleinen
strand geformt hat doch die behörden
waren da vor dem loch zu nahe zu kommen
das jederzeit zu weiteren abbrüchen
kommen kann
entstehen können solche löcher in der
geologie ob doline genannt durch die
wucht des meeres das an die küste brand
oder vielleicht doch durch parkende und
staaten
[Musik]